greetings from podcast Ville it's
Wednesday the 8th of January a beautiful
day to be alive and also Elvis Presley's
[ __ ] birthday who the [ __ ] do you
think you're dealing with Joey bananas
the church is brought to you by stamps
calm listen
time is money baby stop wasting time
going to the post office when you can
use stamps that time no more waiting in
line at the post office like a Momo with
stamps calm you could do everything at
home and save money my wife and I have
been sending out sweatshirts coffee mugs
on stamp coms says Jesus left Chicago
listen we got a seven year old she
turned seven today this is the best
thing that's happened to my wife because
the fries are up and that's it
do me a favor right give yourself a
resolution you can keep stop going to
the post office use stamps calm right
now they got a special offer for the
church family you ready grab a pen a
four-week trial plus postage and a
digital scale then when you're broke
into the lab in high school to steal a
scale now they're sending to you for
free anyway no long-term commitments or
contracts it's easy to go to stamps calm
click the microphone at the top of the
homepage and press in church that
stamps.com press in church and never go
to the post office again I ain't got
nothing against the post office I just
hate waiting online like communists
number two the church what's happening
now is sponsored by zip recruiter listen
to me this is the time of year you're
looking for a job you don't know what to
do Bob when I pop it I pop if you're an
employee employer you're trying to get
the best guy out there okay cuz you
ain't got time listen unit you've got so
much of a budget to get a guy you want
to get the best guy out there and
there's a lot of people walking around
who can you know play the drums and look
through binoculars at the same time it's
a new year take your business to the
next level by iring the right people
find qualified candidates can be
challenging zip recruit accom slash
church makes it nice and easy
they send your job to over a hundred of
the web's leading job boards but they
don't stop there they've got powerful
match
technology they scan through resumes and
find the people with the right
experience to apply for your job right
now today I or da na mañana right now
the church family can't I try zip
recruiter for free what are you saying
free fr EE
at this exclusive address you ready grab
a pen zip recruiter comm slash Church
it's that easy
oh you didn't watch Sesame Street CH you
are CH zip recruited comm / church zip
recruiter the smartest way to high-kick
this [ __ ] melee callers get
little door in there it's going south I
thought that it's great to see you my
Joey unreal to believe that we've both
been in this town for basically the same
amount of time yeah 94 oh my god no you
beat me I got you yeah I'm coming out on
23 years yeah that's a long time doesn't
feel to still be here
well since I moved around a lot and
there's been life changes not so brutal
since I've got things going in a good
direction in terms of family kids
direction career if if it wasn't going
that well I would feel like oh [ __ ] I've
been here a long time I gotta get out I
gotta crawl through [ __ ] pipe with Tim
Robbins the didn't raise my arms up in
the rain and just knowing I hate it but
no I feel good you know I I reminded you
last week when I bumped into you that
you know you getting my first job and
you forgot all about it
I don't remember that and it was - a
friend of yours Jiki smart guy glasses
yeah we shot a short film with cameras
he took out the garbage
from 7-eleven the 7-elevens threw away
all the security cameras he took those
cameras we rigged demand we shot this
film and we he screamed the directors
guild on Sunset and I don't know what I
played they can play the homeless guy
dragging a body or something I don't
remember it's like my first you know and
I always but it was crazy because I
always knew who you were when I started
comedy the big publication was just the
last Oh San Francisco yeah
yes sir they broke down everything that
was going on then you won the year with
93 patton oswalt Marc Maron Stephen B
and Rick currents and my brother
recurrence and called through the
Williamson he Carlton Williamson you
ride you that's the name I've been
trying to come up with look at it just
came out now wow it just came on now Wow
and I was playing Houston years ago
how'd it be 12 years ago I was doing
this shitty room and when I got off
stage it was Colin Williamson mm-hmm and
he came up and introduced himself and
like opposed what happened you took like
fourth in San Francisco I moved down
here because people don't remember that
back in the early nineties those contest
was the biggest danger they were that
you said yeah Johnny Walker red yeah I
won the Becks the next one I did a moose
had won in New York and I was like oh I
was way green
I remember going from Walnut Creek
California the punch line and I won that
section I went to New York and I was so
green and that was from moose and moose
is what you is that it had to proceed to
San Francisco and I want to say is
around 89 or 90 oops look I'm you know
late named TJ Lalo MJ Lalo after that
name yes yes she's a voiceover coach
here in town okay just retired I go I
used to go to her to do all my
voiceovers yeah for vibing audition
there's an office in Burbank
yeah and she was an open mic with you
Wow okay she told me the whole shooting
she knew all the names all the players
people that would come through when she
goes the most memorable guy was Carlos
yeah I always had a reputation as a nice
guy right now please you know yeah
you're the cream of the crop yeah I'm
kind of proud of that moniker I'll wear
it
yeah that's you that's one thing you are
a gentleman if not you wouldn't be on
this [ __ ] yeah with us I'm a nice
Crash Davis you know you all even I
remember going up to you and saying I'm
a dear friend of recurrence even though
Rick's my brother but that time it's not
the kind of name you wanted to drop
around but if you appreciate comedy yeah
and the life that comes with a trick
lives it to the fullest he was the
embodiment of speaking about his paint
he just just breathe that where the next
oh I remember that just hit that phrase
we gotta get to the liquor store that
was one of his bit I don't remember his
obit but he was just you and he and
Marin I thought were very similar they
really both came from a place of kind of
like really dark pain and Oswalt from
his twisted sense of humor but yeah
Kearns is a he was a stand-up guy he was
really nice to me that's all I remember
guy from Denver right yes yeah I just
remember being really honest nice very
there wasn't a dienes at the competition
[ __ ] no he's very straight up very
crazy very uh you know I think about him
a lot just what did Denver and call them
I respect them yes out of town he was in
Tucson taking care of his mother good
but he spent sit through some stuff
right yeah he's been through some stuff
the last few years but he's also he's
been writing on you know white and Larry
the Cable Guy yeah he wrote for two
years for the guy in Vegas uh-huh that
one the best comic of the year so he had
a great job there yeah you know Rick's
had a great career whatever yeah listen
man this is a career that has a lot of
pitfalls oh yeah you know I was part of
those pitfalls for 12 years thank God it
didn't take me down thank God I was a
functioning [ __ ] addict and then a
second big job we booked together was I
get here in 97 first people will say
hello to me nobody ever talked to me no
theatrical agents no management first
people who talked to me a certain Barton
Vanara uh-huh SBV come up to me and
they're like we want you to sign him
well that's not like talking we talk
about commercials yeah they took me down
to Brea across the street from Marie
Callender's at that time no what was the
name of the mall that's now big on La
Brea Wow
I don't know not LaBrea City going in
the middle veg right now that your city
The Grove Oh to grow their offices
across the street who can grow okay
second floor and I still remember going
down and do
paperwork and I'm going what exactly am
I gonna do like well we're gonna send
you out for commercials I'm gonna send
you out for voiceovers have you ever
done like yeah I've done one thing I'm
filming Industrial in a college movie
which I wouldn't shown anybody show us
your real and not no real and then you
know they sent me out for Church's
Chicken I still remember my first art
this yeah on sunset across the street
from the where the hook is I got me yeah
I know that's not your boat plate what
laughs its ship boat didn't Pablo book
that churches changed yeah so Pablo book
that Church's Chicken so I was like [ __ ]
I get it now and I heard what they paid
him and I want mine holy [ __ ] so yeah
those days you went out for auditions
every done yeah you did every day every
day you left the house at 901 and right
your pager
oh yeah while you were you while you
were walking out at 1:00 you were like
yeah go down the [ __ ] what's his name
they want to see your 1:30 it was
mind-boggling how much of your day went
through auditioning you couldn't make
plans this is a hell of a lot less
traffic and more parking too in order to
get it done yeah oh my god you could get
it done I got an avenue yeah gotta go to
Venice gotta go to Hollywood O'Malley
big things were Ocean Avenue and Bundy
yep those are the ones Monday at 4:30
good luck and I went there [ __ ] like
a Korean missile I was [ __ ] headed
there cutting people off and trapped I
just got to do you didn't give a [ __ ]
you pulled into Bundy the guy had a
German Shepherd yeah
the guy that owned the place and Brian
Boy casting you walked in there was
90,000 people in there six rooms and I
still remember they called me in a week
before fourth of July weekend mm-hmm and
they were like you're reading for Taco
Bell Wow
Terry Burrell and for the part of Cuban
taxi driver in Miami and I go okay and
the director was [ __ ] great I forget
what his name was he went out to put me
and eight more commercial uh-huh whether
they wanted me or not
with either we're looking for a Chinese
guy Joey Diaz is to construct yeah
exactly you know he was great to me but
it all started with that commercial
and when in book the callback I spoke a
little Spanish book the callback that
was fourth of July weekend so they gave
it to me on a Friday at 9:30 in the
morning and that one they called they
said listen
Taco Bell scrapped your commercial yeah
but then they want you to come down and
work the three days and vanished right
off folk up the corner from the really
good pizza place that they make it on
bagels Abbot Kinney Pizza AB heavy
Bennis and Electric Avenue come on who
the [ __ ] you think you're dealing with
yeah they used to be in a vacant lot
there
yep that was our base I remember that
yeah yeah I rehearsed for my one-man
show with the daughter of Edmund O'Brien
very famous actors from the 40s who
married okhla son Juan the two sisters
used to live on Willow Crest right next
to me in North Hollywood Marie O'Brien
was his daughter and her house was right
on that empty lot right by that Electric
Avenue so every time I go to rehearse
and go to Abbot Kinney get the bagel
crust pizza every time that's why I know
where it is how [ __ ] great was it
when you had an audition down your thank
God I have it can't be yet to get two
slices of cheese pizza now you know if
instead I don't make it a bikini but
when I'm on that side
I got 1/10 and Wilshire Santa Monica
seafood market I sit at the bar seven
days a week I can get a red clam chowder
Manhattan best clam chowder and fish
that market I'm telling you
well that Hanukkah seafood market 10th
and Wilshire where the hot commercial
police is now I have another conversion
I have been in a ton either there's that
1035 Allison horn is on Sycamore there's
a great one on 1035 Olympic because my
daughter goes a ton my daughter goes on
way more stuff than I do so I know
that's a hot one
Allison Horne is a hot one 200 South
LaBrea is still a hot one who backs I'll
go check on you there's still a big one
over there oh yeah right by the pet cup
uh I was my favorite since I go to Petco
for 44 Lankershim is a pretty good one
for the valley they do a lot of stuff
there Ventura it's on Lankershim there's
a couple on Ventura as well the Torah
and Eureka where the Marshalls clothes
is there's a little commercial audition
yes yeah in the corner yeah they're
pretty much evil one
is up the corner by the carwash yeah
it's a long building yes and that's
where I saw a little Chinese girl what
it was raining out that way huh huh and
all [ __ ] nine Studios were packed and
people standing outside get wet I'm
walking in the sign and go why is out
there people outside getting wet and
there was a little Chinese girl with 20
head shots on the floor and her and her
girlfriends and the mother was deciding
what had shot to use and I was like ah
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] that you wouldn't
look it there's people outside in the
rain yeah and you're standing here but
back to your story
yeah can I go down there the first day
and they say sit in your trailer just
sit for three days if you want something
go get it at crafty I'm sitting at the
lunch they call lunch I'm all eating
together
the directors two tables away and I got
the commercial you know who booked the
principal and that commercial buzz babe
mundo oh never him yeah all right Pete
good guy yeah wife was in Asia yeah buzz
babe mundo was a very decent guy you
know I just got there I've been here six
months I was looking for guidance you
know guys like you I would ask questions
you ask stupid questions
uh-huh and I'm him on that it was three
days if Emily giving me knowledge about
the comedy works and how it worked and
mm-hmm
be careful with this and it was a great
guy so the director heard me talk and
Kisker Kiska Kiska was his name white
dude big dude and he came over to me was
broke just made me laugh my ass off yeah
stick close to me don't you know why I
got an idea he goes why don't you get
your shoes shined and we'll let the dog
run past you
oh that's you so I was getting my shoes
shined
another comedian was a SAG extra he
shined my shoes that's you he what he
looks at the dog goes by that's you in
the chair that's me I'm only happy
it so they shot three the first time
they shot the Miami commercial with the
fat kid that was really really fat
he was the Laugh Factory regular yeah
and he was in cowboy blues Wow
cowboy whatever the first football one
he's the big guy look for him today the
linemen right yeah he lost all the
weight he did the surgery and then now
he's flat nobody wants to give me work
matter of fact guys [ __ ] yourself get
beat yeah yeah
that's your way in the door then you got
to lose weight gradually you can't go
from 900 pounds that 180 that's like you
know just lost your career that's like
getting a free agent that's a fastball
pitcher now a sudden you want to throw a
curveball yeah we gradually to trick
them or fat BOTS look at their head well
he's not fat enough when he was good in
your addition yeah I'm saying buddy you
walk in there looking like you got
cancer that's you he had nine hundred
pounds it's not gonna look good so they
shot three of those commercials uh-huh
and then I found that you were the voice
yeah and you know I never talk about
money on here and never do I talk about
money on here I was [ __ ] eaten when I
booked that commercial my menu pretty
much was breakfast at Joshua's house
mm-hmm
whatever he cooked scrambled eggs tofu
eggs you gotta eat yeah and then I would
scrap up money from somebody Doug
Stanhope Hedberg Wendy's and get the
$0.69 cheeseburger mm-hmm and a bowl of
chili 1996 97 96 97 97 Scott LaRose and
the other guy won five with the
McDonald's kumar's yeah that's right
they want fire Scott Rose is going to
the bank every day I'm banking up a
Brinks [ __ ] truck yeah that's right
Oh playing those McDonald's commercial
was right that Taco Bell commercial I
shot at July 4th weekend I got paid
August 15th [ __ ] September
oh yeah and the success was so
overwhelming that they kept playing it
and play it out and they didn't have
time
scramble like they didn't know the
success of it yeah and then you at the
end yogi no Taco Bell
it had no idea what yeah and ended up
making you know how many more about 40
in the end I did Spanish wants to know
[ __ ] didn't having up whether you do más
rápido
can't this both go any faster yeah I did
a couple Spanish ones I knew at the time
yeah you did like forty years oh I did
forty there's spots that people pull up
today I go I remember that I don't even
remember that was you in that spot and
I've seen that spot several hundred
times that didn't listen they paid me
for a tenth of a second and they made
Fernando Verdugo was his name uh-huh he
doesn't open my comic til this day when
he sees me he hugs me yeah and he was
man thanks because I dragged him with me
i cellphone
stick close yeah awesome guy said he's
gonna put me and don't go to your
trailer he asked it close not too close
I want to got it
Oh bring him in here yeah stick you know
you're running a from Gene Hackman Gene
Hackman always said I never leave this
set yeah I want to see what's going on I
want to get the feel of the set people
widen their trailers the [ __ ]
amateurs yeah so beginning I read that
that's why I learned that yeah and I
hate on him I think I made 80 grand and
fall out the first four months it was
like I couldn't even go to the back I
didn't even have a checking account yeah
because I was wanted by the federal
marshals chuckles I gotta cast my check
yeah Whitley yeah Whitley in Hollywood
that check cashing place even by name
yeah this part of the most of anyone
casually yeah I knew I was be with my
babe and you went with them just became
a voiceover actor yeah pretty much that
kind of helped I was already doing
voiceover I was doing Rocko's Modern
Life and CatDog and then I was touring
and I was in town I worked on a
Stephanie Miller show as a sketch player
in the UPN thirteen weeks of James
Wesley Stevens the third and Karen
Maruyama from the ground was James
Wesley I don't know now what was that
show there's definitely middle is
definitely our show on UPN was a talk
show and we were the irregular regular
so I would do and
to top of show live i would announce TV
show on ABC
I'd have UPN it wasn't me no it was UPN
we filled it in to dr. Phil on stage 29
actually in the Soul Train stages stage
29 in the Paramount a lot 1995 thinkin I
had made it I got a drive-on on the
Windsor gate got my winter card I think
it as the music director he was like
they're cold
he missed the third was Comic Cons did
you impression you know I know we have
no I remember we and we had another
music director was another black guy
forget his name he was very good but it
was a talk show lasted 13 weeks we got
fired at Christmas and I thought POC I'm
gonna go back on the road again
but Stephanie goes no I have a radio
show and you can pay thousand yoki ABC
building on La Cienega where it meets
Fairfax which is now gone they they're
building apartments there and I would go
five days a week and do these radio
sketches from 5:00 to 7:00 they would
play them and I would drive home and
that kept me in town and I wasn't on the
road and there was then at that time
there was an audition right around mid
96 late 96 for Taco Bell with Terry
Burrell and so I was in town because of
this Stephanie Miller connection you
know her TV show was gone but then she
got a radio show again it she goes you
want to do voices and sketches on my
radio show for like $1,000 a week
like that's [ __ ] great money as a
comic at that time yeah instead of going
on the road I could stay here in the
month yeah why not around town yeah I
can do a show yeah get me in town for
that audition and it's four words on a
piece of paper Terry Burrell and
Westside and I'm like yo quiero Taco
Bell this is [ __ ] waste of time
you know how am I gonna get this and are
you guys know I want to hear that about
250 people going hang and then just do
your own voice yo quiero Taco Bell dude
a little deeper yo quiero Taco Ben no
[ __ ] waste of time [ __ ] drive
home you know then I show up the first
session they go act like this is your
body Oh like you're like you're dealing
I mean they act a little tougher like
you killed Uncle Ben
good thank you all right that was a demo
that was like all right thank you
did a demo got paid for the demo and
then next thing I mean I think I just
blew up as as you said and no
and so that changed the scope of my
career from being like for me the road
was always tough it was always I felt
that it is a soulless thing it just
wasn't my love so I was like yes I can
stay in town I can do these commercials
I can and then that booked me more but I
did a [ __ ] Hollywood Squares I'm
talking to Sugar Ray Leonard who at the
time was 44 years old I was 44 he goes
how do you man like I'm talking to Sugar
Ray Leonard you got I go 44 he goes you
got the kids not having kids no how'd
you do that
how'd you pull that off I'm like I'm
about to give Sugar Ray Leonard some
advice of it I don't know I've always
been afraid that I was talking to Sugar
Ray Leonard I heard my name Carlos saúl
was rocky for the block system so I
wasn't hide it felt like I was high
ultra Quarles role was walking through
the block and I'm in the square looking
out at a show I used to watch as a kid
it was all [ __ ] surreal
so yeah strange that we would have these
connections that I've compartmentalised
and forgotten about but that was a free
incredible time because both of our
lives changed respectively yeah I had
all this money coming and I had a
merchandise deal and I had to move out
of my apartment because like you for tax
purposes you need to get a house oh [ __ ]
okay and I bought one in the valley and
modest little how I could afford it I
didn't go nuts I didn't go I'm gonna
live on Sunset Boulevard and imagine
because I'm the tucker belt down my
brother was like there to like no invest
your money yeah [ __ ] buy a house you
can afford put it in an in a financial
market planning thing do all those
things which I did and it paid off but
yeah our lives change you know you go
from having I had a moderate amount of
money I lived in a studio apartment in
Burbank I was paying 695 a month for a
studio apartment and doing some
voiceover work and doing some comedy on
the road to pay for that and then this
thing happened and it's I've always
spoken about how every comedians journey
is different yes you know I - if I can
have it my way
now at this point in my life I wouldn't
go on the road yes but I do love it so
much he's still over yeah I still love
it to go out twice a month yeah my body
I don't
rather check I can't come do you do a
weekend I'll do a weekend Friday
Saturday Friday and Seth horse shows
travel with a comic you know and like
yes that big difference I would do that
big difference I would do I get my
choices I don't work Sundays I'd like to
travel on Thursdays from time to time if
I want to work out material I'll take a
service day and special local improv
like I'm doing Brian March yeah yeah
it's not too far you're in touch with
your family you could bring them if you
want
yes no I don't try to bring them I want
them mercy would never leave school yeah
she got a trophy the first year for
perfect attendance and never being late
yeah Jesus comes to battle with the
Jonas Brothers she's not she's gonna go
for so yeah you could that's good okay I
got a fiber I didn't want to do that
with my career I didn't want to involve
them in that Road thing because it's
really not what I'm into yeah it's one
of the many weapons that I use yeah it's
definitely a suit of armor if you're
playing Dungeons & Dragons that's a tool
to have like I'm a comedic my comedian
armor you can't hurt me you know yeah no
no so that's this is I like what I'm
doing now you know I like the split yeah
it's when I tell people I when you get
sick of saying those jokes yeah then you
shouldn't be on the road yeah get the
[ __ ] off the road cuz you're doing them
a disservice yeah you know they got a
babysitter they need you just beam
robotic you're on your eighth week in a
row yeah that's right Oh No
so I'd rather now I'm reforged and I can
do theaters seven o'clock show perfect
nobody's drinking no they get two drinks
outside they said chicken wings you're
lucky I'm trying to avoid late shows cuz
I lost contact yeah with the people come
to the shows because you have to do two
shows you're gonna be in that area yeah
and the theaters like listen we'd like
for you to come out but if not we're not
gonna start the second show till
midnight like that you know you know my
daughter Austin I nicknamed her when she
was a baby I nicknamed her Friday second
show because I couldn't [ __ ] make her
laugh
I go your Friday Late Show I can't
[ __ ] make you laugh oh you yeah this
is comic do you remember when that was
the rep you that was the big thing I can
Friday Friday late you're in no danger
because they're really tired they made a
mistake they drunk day they made a
mistake they made a mistake who is this
guy I'm drunk you worked all week I
don't even know some idiot a girl at
work the chubby girl at work always
brings a pound cake yeah you know the
Julie McCoy of the office yeah every
office has all those chubby chicks
nothing against you you're cute they get
drunk will suck your little dick from
time to time you know me too that chubby
that's just the way they always schedule
these things and people don't know
that's why I don't do New Year's yeah
it's the same under New Year's people
and I did 24 of them yeah I ain't a
party favor anymore I did 24 of them and
two of them were probably good yeah
because it's just a nightmare you know I
don't want to I never want the audience
and I'm yeah I want them to [ __ ]
laugh and have a great time and you know
well Joey was great he did four hours
listen I don't want to see [ __ ]
nobody to four hours yeah no I get I
there's like the staffing to do four
hours yeah 15 minutes if foam there's
one bit that's been working too close
will do in the hour and we get the [ __ ]
out get out so you don't lose your
attention span
you guys good give more leaving wanting
more the staff love you everybody gets
to go home everybody says justice that
just to let you know yeah thirteen
million people saw the Irishman
yeah I'm Netflix one week eighteen
percent of them finished yeah okay yeah
you know when you put a thing on Netflix
now it's all done by algorithms but
they're seen if your show gets watched
all the way to the end you're a hit yeah
like you definitely get them picked up
if it gets stopped and then replayed
again they consider all those yes it's
so [ __ ] weird
it is yeah Netflix will never give you
your real numbers now so confusing yeah
but I'm the same way I just want to do
50 minutes
get off the stage yeah talk to them yeah
I have two shows I can't really talk
yeah some of my favorite weekends when I
was I was Garcia narrator number one the
Taco Bell dog was still just tail end of
it and I've got to travel with Jill
Michelle Mele on and we were like-minded
we'd like to get out during the day and
go do stuff and walk through cemeteries
and go to TGI Fridays after the show and
not get crazy but just talk about the
show she's somebody I bonded with and I
remember if I had that situation again
I would do a weekend like you I would go
to tempie I'd even go all the way across
coast just to do a weekend that I could
see myself doing again Robin said Friday
it's Saturday so you knew was somebody I
really liked trendy with live on the
road now it's also an escape from what's
going on here
yeah it's an escape from the phone ring
and this guy wanna pitch your script
mm-hmm you know this that this I don't
worry about that I'm on the road mm-hmm
you know that's why people contact me
would you do my podcast and love to yeah
but I'm on the road yeah I'm doing
[ __ ] comedy yeah don't ask I'm doing
honey wanna do radio yeah I'm doing
stand-up I'm not selling t-shirts yeah
I'm not selling merch yeah I'm just
doing for [ __ ] shows yeah and I want to
be so focused that I want to give me the
best show so you come back next year
yeah that's it that's it
18 months in between cities so that's
perfect probably yeah there's turnover
there yep don't even remember oh yeah
and if you do throw a gemin from the old
school they'll appreciate yeah you know
nobody wants to go see Zeppelin and not
hear black dog I know a lot of people
don't talking about it but I thought it
was something that was interesting was
you City Taco Bell and were 44 oh gosh
talk about 1990 16 I was born in 1962 so
34 right okay
is that right does that make sense yeah
I was around Europe 34 okay
oh I was very like the well know Sugar
Ray Leonard was 44 cotton okay 10 years
on me so I didn't fight him okay but
it's a lot of people coming in there
like I was watching Spade and Santa talk
about beer in lesson L
25 yeah and that's pretty you guys both
came here and started semi late sorry
for it's not super late but yeah
till I get a big break at that age did
it help you 32 when I moved here 94 yeah
it does because you're more a little bit
more grounded I mean I've grown a lot
since then but yeah it wasn't some 20
year old kid because if I did get talked
about when I was 24 I bought that house
on Sunset yeah
and limos for the yeah all that [ __ ] I
would have blown the bitch's topless
[ __ ] money out the window I did buy
an Audi TT that was my one big expense
it's really crazy the maturity maturity
does to yet haves game what a kid does
when what a kid does life kid it's not
just maturity people looked at it as all
my ideas it's hard to work with like
right now you know people hit me up
every week I'm more I do better on the
internet sorry
two weeks I get we have a web series
yeah not for nothing
look at your [ __ ] web series I'm
gonna have to go on and carry this
[ __ ] thing on my own I'm gonna get
the quality wait it mm-hmm
you don't you can't pay me for that yes
that's not even the thing you know so
it's like I really don't die I don't
even know what the topic was here that
working young youth how to handle you
sustain youth and fame coming up tea and
stuff
I couldn't I told we if this would have
happened 15 years ago this would have
been gone by now yes because you would
have probably gone for something else I
would have yeah I'm gonna stand up and
done coke yeah yeah and this would have
been like wasn't I wasn't consistent
yeah I wasn't and those are the reason
why I wasn't getting a lot what was
spinning my wheels yeah but it's so
weird how how many people have you seen
come no a lot quite a few everything the
most famous is Richard Jeni you know no
no no I'm not talking about people died
well I know what yeah yeah yeah the the
flame the 15 minutes of fame that bomb
who came here with you yeah and you
struggled for years and the whole sudden
you moved a little ahead of him and they
pea lost his sight and one day you
actually because not because you're a
bad person but
because there's so many little things
going on in your life one day you
actually go yeah and you pick up the
phone yeah buddy and he's like yeah how
you doing I tried to call you but I
think you out of town we moved we moved
back to Oakland yeah I'm some real
estate now and Mark Curry's the guy I
saw toplane recently good old mark I
don't I just bumped into him he's doing
spots again I think he's doing Sparky
when I was naturally funny guys
everybody came up with more kind yeah
here at whoa at that time he was running
Oakland yeah here I still remember him
running Oakland when he got his TV show
yeah there was no sir mr. Hooper mr.
history yeah Thank You mr. Cooper well
hey you know you gotta remember when I
got into comedy all you guys had already
been exposed yeah through MTV Kamikaze
yeah Sunday cut our comedy Rosie
O'Donnell's
yeah you know there was so much comedy
when I got into comedy
I went home every day at 4 o'clock yeah
Club MTV whatever comedy kamikaze was on
yeah and they would shoot it from San
Francisco so I still remember seeing
Felicia and yeah Marin and you know
these are the guys and at that point
they were all doing comedy for five
years yeah they weren't really like
power hitters you know they're pretty
young Stern had that Shaunie and he on
Sundays uh any yet Sunday comics comedy
police company at The Improv any save a
tease at The Improv do you need Tommy at
the improv with Budd Friedman if you
remember oh and Buddy introduced to me
and I got to shake his hand after the
set Wow I made it so you didn't in
Prague that for you yeah
way back when yeah I did a bunch of
shows Gary Bynum's comedy on the road in
Mexico and Puerto Verta
you remind them from comedy on the road
with Gary Bynum know a different Gary
Gary binder binder okay is it Gary
binder the comedian John binder sorry
John binder Gary Bynum was a guy in
Arizona John binders comedy on the road
we did it from Puerto valley by Jeff box
yeah how does it feel to be one of the
elders now it feels pretty good like I
say I'm a nice Crash Davis I've been in
this business for a long time and so
when I go to flappers and young comics
are you know flapping their peacock
feathers and stuff I'm just like oh
that's awesome that's good for you I get
like I always feel like I got mine I'm
cool I feel I feel good I feel I was
very young when I approached it and I
approached it from I wanted to be like
this comic and that come in that come it
was never really myself it was a good
performer I could do voice I could I can
make a good set happen that has never
really me so now I feel still like I'm
young at comedy but it still feels good
to be the the old guy because rap to
Taco Bell what started happening after
Taco Bell
that would took 2000 that ended in 2000
the Michigan ad company sued Taco Bell
because they said we came in before chef
day we came up with the ad and you guys
passed us they won that lawsuit
Taco Bell ended in 2000 I'm like [ __ ]
I'm panicking now I got to go out in the
rush of myself back out on the road
again I didn't like it at least I got to
travel with gildo so it was bearable it
was fun and then in 2000 Christmas of
2000 No 9/11 was 2001 right 9/11 was
2001 9/11 happens I do I did some
industrial thing for DirecTV I was
making a commercial and then December of
2001 I did a movie we Ellen Page called
I downloaded a ghost Ellen Page of
course is super famous but I played it
her ghost and you can you can see it
somewhere I did October right after 9/11
I did a movie for Nickelodeon in
Saskatoon Saskatchewan for one month
come back and in December there's an
audition for Ben Tom and Carrie for the
sketch show called Ugly Americans Jersey
television John Landgraf who now I think
still runs FX and Danny DeVito's company
Jersey films then I going do this three
characters for Ben Tom and Carrie do the
Shamim Oh Michael a guy that's telling
him you know a cocktail napkin looks
like a cocktail no did that guy I did a
booty Alan do you Sunni and then I did a
Al Pacino as a as a as a children's
birthday clown which actually got me a
commercial with Spike Lee
so I did those characters December they
said yeah you're going to studio you go
to network I booked the Ugly Americans
as a sketch player with niecy Nash Ben
Tama carry and ceedric and this woman
named Amy Brissette who's now living in
st. Charles reminded this great lady Amy
possess super super nice super 10
children hi Amy
your amazing talent is a great way that
we spoke she might come on the podcast
when she comes up she played my daughter
and we do this pilot we actually go to a
table read for Fox Gail Berman and we do
all our sketches that Ben and Tom Carey
wrote and me she's doing her thing I
remember she played a cute cute
television slave like there was a slave
for sale on Q TV it's pretty
inappropriate but we do all these
sketches they they the meeting ends and
then next day that like fox is passing
on this show it's not gonna happen but
you still got a budget we've got one
week to come up with something meet us
at the sunset Gower studio on Monday we
have an idea we're gonna go we're gonna
make fun of cops go home and think about
a character we're gonna call it Reno 911
I went home and I thought Barney five
self-loathing kind of a racist he's a
prick Garcia doesn't think he's Mexicans
hates other Mexicans he's all
law-abiding that kind of guy and I
showed up Beth McCarthy from SNL was
there we filmed all these sketches we
rehearsed we went out to San Pedro and
making a crew laugh we're making the
[ __ ] gaffers and the lighting and the
electric guys laugh when we go that's
[ __ ] good that's like making the
staff laugh at a comedy club you know
you got something
so 2001 we do that pilot in San Pedro
for Reno know what we do it it's great
we think it's awesome take it to Fox
whoo we have to deal with him they go
now we're passing really ah [ __ ] oh well
we tried and then a year and a half
later back out on the road actually
instantly in 2000 went back on the road
and then a year and a half later uh Jim
sharp requests material from Ben Tom and
Kerry because they had done the Viva
variety show and in the state and they
said we got this pilot that we shot Reno
911
and so we reshot that pilot shot for
shot for Comedy Central in 2003 and then
off it went and that's pretty much the
one good Reno dime
premiere I think 2003 June of 2003 I
want to say they just took off took off
it's amazing
was it before or after Chappelle store
do you know what do you remember it was
simultaneous okay and I remember us
being a jealous of Chappelle's ratings
you know and then to write at the same
time okay you have two wonderful shows
that are just strong and great and
inventive and that's what I wanted to do
that's when I found out that voiceover
and on acting on camera acting fed me
more than stand up like standing but
that's what I love and it's coming back
actually on kwibi
we could talk about that in the future
RINO's coming back on Katzenberg
streaming channel we're set to film
probably end of January beginning of
February for kwibi they bought 120
minutes of material the original cast
will be back Wendy mclendon-covey from
the Goldbergs bad from the Goldbergs
ceedric nisi from claus obviously
ceedric from many things but we're all
back we're all gonna do little sketches
and we'll see how it goes but after 10
years you know I also got to reprise
Rocko's Modern Life after 25 years we
did static cling which was last year so
all these things were coming back and
that's that's how my career tracked I I
was doing comedy to sort of survive and
pay the bills but voiceover came with
Rocko's Modern Life in 1991 1992 I
remember being at the last laugh in
Seattle on a payphone
and I was eating my clam chowder and it
was fine I was headlining the last laugh
it was lonely and then I saw the Broncos
go into series and I jumped up and down
thing and my thing was I can get off the
road now I have I have an animated
series I was so happy it was probably my
best sets ever because I didn't care you
know I I don't need this anymore and
then I started with Rocco and I was
weaving that that thing at the same time
and now these days voice-over is more of
my career I go out on auditions for
on-camera stuff you haven't seen you own
apps I'll whisper booth yeah it's in the
in the garage so the kids can't get to
me
I can lock the garage and it's gold my
whisper booth shut it do my auditions
with a little plug-in mic on my phone
it's go better than that
I'm gonna have to yeah mp3 it's a motive
it's a MZ 88 sure Mike it's right in the
end of the phone but so that's pretty
much what I do now but that's how it
tracked but yeah there was like
significant change I was you know and
relative to how the competition went for
Marc Maron and Patton Oswald who went on
our super prominent now and I won and I
was always the curse of the second in
the first place I Robin Williams came in
second you know you know I think it was
either patent or Marc Maron that came in
second
well I thought will I be the curse of
the winner of the competition yeah I
don't have Patton Oswald notoriety or
Marc Maron at notoriety but I went the
way I was supposed to go and then I had
you know I got married in 2009 I have
two daughters as you know and this feels
right if super big Fame comes along
that's fine if not I like doing what I'm
doing like you love doing this I love
going to our or martial arts class with
the kids and it's just comfortable for
me it's it's like I don't need I'm not
want for like to make a speech at some
award show you know if it happens it's
fine going to the cons meeting fans I
like going to the cons more than I do
stand-up because stand-up as you know if
you aren't with somebody that you dig
it's it's a prison sentence it's like ah
I gotta get out of this [ __ ]
apartment or condo I gotta go walk
somewhere to the mall okay that killed
an hour and a half now [ __ ] what I
don't feel like writing I'm depressed
and it's Wednesday and it's [ __ ]
Wednesday that's Wednesday the cons I
fly in on a Thursday night I go to a
steak I got a beautiful steak place to
sit at the bar have a little whiskey a
little beer get my appetite going I go
back home I work out in the pool in the
morning I go and I'm on the floor all
day with people who think I'm great yeah
I'm jealous of Tom Kenny's big line but
[ __ ] that I people love me I'm signing
autographs I get to interact with fans
that they tell you what they mean to you
much more polite than comedy crowds you
know they're not drunk their kids their
families I make money I love it because
I'm around people all day and then at
night the the con agents and organizers
say we're going out to dinner with Oh
David Harbor and and Sean Astin and I'm
included awesome so I would love to do
or cons as opposed to doing stand-up on
the road but I would do booth both so
this is the life that I'm doing now and
it happened despite what I thought I
wanted you know when we were younger I
want this [ __ ] show I want this movie
what can I be like that guy and then
you're like okay this is [ __ ] yes
see that's what Peter at 57 to first off
you had no curse yeah curse would have
been if you would have been a realtor
right now yeah
own your own company right now there's
nothing wrong with that yeah and there's
nothing wrong with evolving I just saw
but me that show where are you now who
are they now and they show this guy that
was on the road with like Bon Jovi and I
just paint houses yeah not in the
irishman kind of way no yeah he's having
a good life and he's doing he put away
his money he bought a home and he
secured his family's future yeah and he
really wanted a paint the road wasn't
for him anymore yeah you know I was
watching the Guns and Roses thing when
one day is he just didn't want to be in
the band oh yeah it just wasn't for me
anymore you know whatever when you
become a comedian when you first got out
of that open mic stage some people don't
want to move to California and be a star
did you know that oh yeah don't so a lot
of SF comics don't want to move to LA in
May no job some people want to stay in
Chicago yeah
entertain locally you know do a couple
weekends in Indiana or Milwaukee Jack
Gallagher was that guy Jack Gallagher I
think won the competition and was from
Boston moved to San Francisco got his
show in LA letters to Declan was his
one-man show that got him the TV show it
ended he moved back to Sacramento became
the Altadena dairy or some dairy
spokesman loved it in Sacramento but a
nice house and the beautiful I think the
color the beautiful 80s the beautiful
30s like eight is enough house in
Sacramento and that's what he wanted he
goes I'm done
I love Sacramento I did my television
show I'm a great comic I love it here
and that I remember that that's sunk
into me that that's nothing to me I went
okay Wow
you can't there's no shame in loving
what you love no check but this is
here's what I'm learning sometimes I
want to give up and just like I'm
[ __ ] so business is not fair and
[ __ ] I'm gonna go [ __ ] just you
know own a sports club in Canada and I'm
like now I still want to be creative I
still want to do those old movies and
pull [ __ ] cameras out of her carbage
can and do that [ __ ] again you know I
still want to write stuff and make stuff
happen and that's the important thing is
like I still for all of us stay creative
and let the chips fall where they may do
what you love stay creative think of
something go for it and it'll happen I
made a movie I made a movie called
Witness infection I financed it myself
Maurice LaMarche Tara Strong Erin Hayes
Rob Belushi Jo Michelle Mele on myself
Bret Ernst plays my son Dominic it'll
come out we'll have a screening but it's
called Witness infection you can go to a
website but I made it I want to [ __ ]
make this movie will I ever get
financing no I won't [ __ ] it I'm paying
for it let's do it so I put it on the
money and showed up the first day there
was an all-in-one truck there's craft
service and here's Erin Hayes and here's
Rob Belushi and they're acting and
something that I wrote with Jill and we
created something will it make my money
back hopefully maybe we're gonna
premiere it at the hostel in San Antonio
in February and hopefully it'll get some
fests of other festivals we'll have an L
a screening let's see what happens but I
[ __ ] made it I made it I made a [ __ ]
film feature film executive produced it
wrote it acted in it and I didn't know
how that happen I don't know how it
happened I didn't set how to do it so it
was in the curse there's no curse yeah
how comes I know it okay I got my family
I live in a really cool place there's no
curse it's really weird when you move
here the state of mind you have and then
one day when you for me it was I got
here in 97 I knew what I wanted
I knew what I didn't want to there's no
more I knew what I was gonna do yeah
what I wasn't gonna do no more I made
all those decisions like in 2008 and I
think and I said this is what its gonna
be you're not gonna have a B Cyrus oh
yeah
I'm not ever gonna be Kevin Hart and I
could blame him a system or whatever no
it's not even what I want yeah I can't
even imagine running from people or
walking into an arena and having to do
good morning anyway and talking to
[ __ ] some lady and I can't imagine
those things yeah I just wanted to be
happy after 2009 mm-hmm and all of a
sudden this venture opened up the
podcast world opened up and I opened I
started doing a podcast with Felicia and
it was just great it was a different
creative outlet mm-hmm was it what I
intended to do when I first got on stage
and not really and that's what makes
this fun and that's what made this all a
father this is another expected you time
yeah and that opened up 52 other avenues
you know yeah
one day I tell a story on an Ari Shaffir
show he starts that the [ __ ]
Hollywood improv lab yeah it goes
digital the next thing in a minute for
three years or four years on network Wow
you know and I gotten a piece of that so
it's like somebody told me when when
you're 20 when we're young we come here
and we're looking for the home run
yep and then we turn into a rocker oh
and then and then when they in 2009 we
become Pete Rose yeah we can contact
header the little hits you up for Pete
our little singles little singles yeah
but every time a single yeah every two
times a single and God forbid there's a
guy on third yeah drop it but there's a
guy up there and I'm gonna hit a single
on you yeah I went from swinging for the
hall and that makes your life so much
easier
yeah well if I get this film with
Travolta and this I could do the
weekends and sell arenas no you're not
yeah no you know that's just something
you put in your [ __ ] mind
yeah go in there do the best you can and
then worry about that
at the store the night of the improv
without all the Laugh Factory or
whatever the [ __ ] you got yeah like
there's a there's a point of where your
mind is when you get here and it's a
point after you've been beat up and
kicked a little bit yeah told you're not
Mexican so you can't do a road you're
perfect for yeah you put it all together
you learn who to live with who to avoid
yeah I'm avoid that [ __ ] cuz
every time he talks to mr. he's the kiss
at that yeah all his pride you suck
anyway yeah you know the projects are
great until it comes time to promote
they don't know nobody yeah then the
cousin at CBS died you something though
yeah do I kind of cousin at CBS she
could definitely give it to moose moose
love that [ __ ]
yeah I'm shoot and all sudden you get a
call one day she got fired yeah they
laugh got caught stealing they fired
everybody at the top do you have anybody
who you could pitch it to you look like
Johnny pitcher yeah I'm trying to
[ __ ] do spots I'm trying to go Jimmy
show Shella yeah I'm done dude three
[ __ ] minutes
yeah yeah any kinds are you doing a year
now how many cuz I did four or five I'd
like to do up to ten and I thought
hopefully with this Reno news that it
would get me at least ten this Reno news
was huge it was huge it was really cool
and I was happy for their fan base yeah
you guys had a unique [ __ ] fan base
yeah well that was very very loyalty
yeah I saw it somewhere and I was like
wow I didn't know Arena then you guys
did a movie yet yeah reno 9-1-1 miami
mind 9 2006 brother sorry
yeah I did my first hosting weekend on
the road and it was in Reno and I
wouldn't saw the sign that that's why I
asked a bunch of pal because that was it
was before time with the internet
because it was the with the sketches
like you could see some parts of it and
it would be funny by itself yeah Stan
and like I think it was interesting what
you said Joey about Netflix about how
not that many things get finished
because I think if you looked at it the
most popular things on streaming or 22
minutes tops
oh yeah cuz it's short you can watch a
little clips on online you see the whole
thing we don't know I want one like I
was gonna ask you guys how cool is it
like you've done things that maybe
weren't didn't get picked up or worn
that critically like whatever but you
guys both have things that are gonna be
remembered for 50 years
yeah pretty iconic lassic with both the
Taco Bell and this show and we're
learning now algorithms based on what
kwibi wants how the kids are watching
they're watching vertically so shoot it
this way but when you tilt your phone
sideways it'll pick up something else in
the shot here's the length that needs to
be here's how we're gonna change here's
what we're gonna do so they've got a
formula of how this new Reno is gonna be
it'll be a lot of it'll be the same but
a lot of it will be just the
crunchberries you know what I mean
before was Captain Crunch with crunch
berries now the kids just want mostly
the crunch berries a little bit of
Captain Crunch crunch berries boom go
move on Oprah's a 10-minute one the
we're up to 10 minutes but I think
they're finding the perfect length it's
gonna be six to eight minutes
they're basically they're gonna pay for
120 minutes of material
we're probably gonna shoot 200 and see
how much we can you want to keep going
and then we're just gonna show it we'll
get a guy like Nick Swardson who played
Terry in the shorts boom Boop give me
[ __ ] hand jobs the intersection will
get him on one day and we'll shoot 10
sketches with him and just knock it out
and monetize it and then we'll get toby
huss who played a character by mike toby
huss we'll do 10 sketches with him get
it out of the way niecy Nash plays Tee
tee
she's the girl with the jokes oh ma
would have told him he was midgets
we'll shoot ten things with her get it
out of the way because now we have to
shoot catch-as-catch-can because Wendy
and ceedric and Tom and Niecy are very
busy so we're literally gonna shoot when
we can weekend's try to do morning
breathing when we get everybody just
shoot a bunch of more two days of
morning briefings rattle them all out
and then just plug it in plug it in it's
like a puzzle and then it'll be back
again like magic like this is like
instant oatmeal this turnaround as
opposed to you know steel-cut 20 minutes
oatmeal will make it'll be just as good
we're all excited we had a dinner two
weekends ago three weekends ago and just
to see everybody again and you know it's
like fact the gang is back the gang is
back so that you talked about starting
something for the new year which sets
your year and that when I found out that
news finally that this was gonna come
back and the money that they're
negotiating with cuz got some bird have
some good money I'm like I'll take
whatever I'm like I'm not a whatever you
want to give me
take but if you say we can negotiate for
more okay I'll take it so and it's weird
I don't know about you I don't only in
terms of helping pay for this movie that
I financed I don't really think about oh
I get so much money I think about I get
to be creative again yeah
it's so weird how at this age the money
is I've got enough I've made some good
investments you always want more you can
always gonna need more but it's like
that doesn't move the needle for me it's
like no we're doing Reno again that's
why I said whatever you want to [ __ ]
pay me I'm fine I'm down I'll be there
I'm doing comma in Spanish this year oh
really
yeah I'm starting let's pray just in
Miami yeah the only ones I don't
understand what the [ __ ] I'm saying oh
yeah
the Cuban axle is doing this Braun yo
yeah I'm doing the name of my show is uh
me no biggie no biggie I love it
you know and I understand one man show
that what ya trying to put a one-man
show we got a little work out once a
month the communist or the third
Wednesday of the month yeah you know
we'll go anywhere I've no idea I want to
see you on star anise a prequel yeah no
no I'm not [ __ ] Hanna it's a complete
difference its are you gonna be on it
it's the prequel you should be on it I
am you are on it yeah I shot it already
that's of course young the 25th it comes
great how was it how was Gandolfini son
tremendous really nice kid yeah what a
guy that I'm really impressed a couple
guys impressed me but David Chase is
different level yeah different comedic
you voted about his family he's a tired
yeah his name is like David Cheney glad
yeah yeah yeah he's uh he's quite the
[ __ ] character so no Michael Imperioli
no no this is all uh-huh Joe you're
perfect for that that's gonna that's
gonna launch us in 1966 ah
Wow so I'll go junior who's younger the
juniors younger yeah
Anthony's a kid dude you're in yeah no I
really had I really liked me and my eyes
right now I got the podcast I got my
daughter I like going to the store twice
a week mm-hmm I think I go down
last night Saturday and Sunday but I
don't I'm not big on the TV and film
though huh
especially after doing the podcast and
doing this with your own rules and your
own beliefs it's pretty much to go on
anymore
yeah I'm script he come up to me and say
the word is the yeah not V and you know
I you know I want to be [ __ ]
autonomous so you understand it nobody
watches this show yeah exactly nobody's
gonna come up to me on the train and go
hey I saw you yes every time they come
up to me they just take the [ __ ] gun
away from me yeah if I do something it's
cuz I really want to do it yeah you're
gonna shoot me out first in the morning
it but it's difficult gently [ __ ]
lurking around all [ __ ] day like I'm
Luke on a TV show
shoot me out like Tracy Morgan before I
start me doing [ __ ] yeah okay so what
do you want to have me to [ __ ] a [ __ ]
campaign yeah well me getting the [ __ ]
out of here at 12:00 just shoot me and
call those out these people were paid to
stick around for 12 hours want the best
of me yeah
58 57 57 yeah oh yeah I don't have time
you're not gonna catch me yeah I'm gonna
go out there I'm not gonna want to be I
know myself I lose the energy yeah so if
it's something that that yes I'm in the
monsters remake I'm grandpa yeah you
know when when uh she shot psychiatrist
shut the Sopranos her scenes were all
done in one day
oh wow okay that's what she negotiated
lorraine bracco
so I come in Tuesday's in hospital ain't
Brock I'll shoot six - [ __ ] - a
morning yeah I don't give up I'll shoot
25 hours true yeah I want to do it in
one day huh that did something that
would interest me yeah I don't want to
learn before 12-hour days yeah we got
the girls yeah nothing a girls you got
to be home for dinner yeah you gotta be
home to help them with their homework
you gotta be home help to bathe yeah
gotta be home to talk to them it's not
they're gonna bump into
some [ __ ] guy Bikram yoga yeah
exactly [ __ ] hummus dick yeah I don't
want that all because you shot four days
before you shot 112 hour days yeah for a
little bit change that you really cuz
it's not like that pan yeah what they
were paying when you and I got here yeah
they're not even paying close to that
[ __ ] now you're not so it's not really
one of my things anymore yeah it used to
be I love that thing I loved movies yeah
but now who's gonna see you in a movie
yeah so any choice wasn't the Merc
married and anything really that the
needle move after the Joker I mean the
best movie of the year needle should
have moved a little bit yeah you should
have gone from selling the Improv out
maybe two weeks of the improper may have
an extra Wednesday yeah saying that
those days are done
yeah those days are done but uh what are
you gonna do we just keep pluggin
brother yeah I whatever comes my way
stay creative really work on this movie
finish this thing do some more stand-up
I'm doing some sets to prepare for the
ha festival but HBO MS thing I'm doing
seven to eight minutes and we talked
about it called read at The Improv
because I don't want to just rest at
flappers and we wrap comfortable but I
make sure things are funny and we'll see
what come from that but I remember I was
to offer a possibility of doing an hour
special or whatever is special and I was
on the table for it and I said we forget
it's fine if not that's fine I'm fine
either way
an hour no long [ __ ] it's a long time I
mean when you haven't been writing for
sure oh yeah and you gotta go out every
night and having one of your friends
India yeah and give him a couple dollars
to yeah guide you along the way but make
a fine young Carlos I was rocky calm
Carl that was rocky calm on Twitter at
Carlos Ellis rocky Instagram Carlos
Ellis rocky as well even on tick tock do
some videos for the Casas Grandes which
I'm doing for Nickelodeon and yeah I'll
be Rudy Moreno actually he just I guess
he's made it public he had a heart
attack
leave it and he's allowed me to do a set
on an all-woman's show on the 8th which
is uh tomorrow night in Pasadena with Jo
Michelle Malley on and a couple of great
female comics and I'll be on flappers on
18th - and 8 o'clock 10 o'clock guest
spots in Burbank and that just be
everywhere yeah and then I do my
Stephanie Miller radio show once a week
you still do it
I still do it once a week I wake up at
4:30 6 to 9
yeah good for her I hosted this last
time Carl's just been a real niala to
have you yeah that's not a I don't
understand if you know how real you are
now well thanks what an impact you've
had on my career and uh you're just a
great guy you deserve I read all the
success that you got I'm happy for the
clip show yeah women will have you on
here for the premiere yeah let's do it
no and when witness infection comes out
we'll do the same we'll do the same and
I'll get bread on yeah right okay great
guys that's him he called me a couple
weeks with this [ __ ] mother in the
car yeah and we just went at it yeah his
mother knows the same people you know
mother grew up like Jersey guys yes
my wife's in Jersey he knows the whole
[ __ ] yeah the mother knows that Jimmy
Hoffa was barely yeah yeah she's well
minutes late for my burial yeah well
thank you very much coming on
do not forget go to college I was rocky
calm and check out when he comes to your
town whether to do comedy or whether
it's just a one-time let's say you're a
[ __ ] big-time reno911.com there say
hello tell him that you heard of him on
here and he'll [ __ ] give you an extra
autograph all right yeah listen I want
to give a shout out to my sponsors who
are the best like I told you earlier
listen time is money baby stop wasting
their time going to the post office when
you can use stamp that's calm all you
need is a computer to print postage 24/7
any letter any size package going
anywhere in the world right from your
couch you're the post office now jack
and the best part is the mailman will
come and pick it up no more lugging
boxes down to the post office more time
to get things done you got no excuses
and stamps calm is actually cheaper than
the post office get five cents off every
first-class stamp up to 40% off Priority
Mail never pay full price again how many
more times am I gonna schlep to the post
office how many more times are you gonna
schlep to the post office in your life
how many that
stop leaving money on the table sign up
with stamps.com today no more waiting
online the post office like a Momo with
stamps calm you do everything from your
house and you save money
I love stamps calm my wife loves
stamps.com and I'm telling you if you
don't have stamps you're losing out so
do me a favor
right now give yourself a resolution you
gotta stick to it
go to stamps calm right now they're
running a special offer for the church
family you ready a four-week trial plus
postage and the digital scale no long
notes long-term commitments or contracts
it's easy go to stamps calm click on the
microphone at the top page of the
homepage and press in church that's it
that stance calm press in church never
go to the post office again you're
hiring aren't you zip recruiter is the
answer
listen it's tough out there for a pimp
kids are grown graduating by the day
there's a lot of good employees and
there's a lot of dead people out there
it's a new year take your business to
the next level by hiring the right
people finding qualified candidates can
be challenging 8 you're talking to the
man himself but zip recruiter doc coms
last Church makes it easy
how long for Joey zip recruiter sends
jobs oh to over a hundred of the web's
leaving job boards but they don't stop
there with their powerful matching
technology zip recruiter scans thousands
of resumes to find people with the right
experience to apply for your job as
applications come in zip recruit
analyzes each one and spotlights the top
candidates so you never miss a great
match
zip recruit is so effective that four
out of four four out of five employers
who post on zip recruit it get a quality
candidate within the first 24 hours in
the first day listen that's tremendous
right now you'd go to zip recruiter for
free at this exclusive app dress zipper
guru.com
slash church Joey what was that zip
recruiter com slash shirts
typical
the smartest way the hi I want to thank
super Krewe de I want to thank
stamps.com and I want to thank CBD Lian
most importantly I want to thank Carlos
I was rocky my brother thanks and the
[ __ ] comin at you for the
Spanish people listen happy Christmas
today's we celebrate we [ __ ] we Cubans
today's the three wise men yeah so you
have to [ __ ] for good luck well like
the Jews we gotta [ __ ] give somebody a
little money if I find out you [ __ ]
don't go to happy hour sushi and I want
you there with three old I'll leave
right now don't go out on a box I'm
taking that [ __ ] money back oxide
that's how I roll it's Cuban Christmas
today give somebody your love with 20
pennies now you're not going you at
least not without today's the day when
the three guys showed up in Cuba so
today is an extra Christmas so when your
Cuban your parents test you like you
were good all year [ __ ] let's see how
you're gonna act Christmas to the 7 yeah
that's when you get all your [ __ ] now
you don't need me no more playing over
time so my mom gave you cash so after
Christmas I had to still keep it under
control once the seventh came and go
[ __ ] yourself I sleep in the garage I'm
saying but I'm the sixth you shoulda
seen me sweeping mopping up paint
alright you can suck my dick shovel the
[ __ ] driveway yourself take an
aspirin [ __ ] anyway don't forget that
week Fox neither in Bakersfield Friday
night Saturday night power in Fresno and
then we just had a second shot at the
Tabernacle Theatre in Atlanta Georgia on
the 25th of January pre-super Bowl
[ __ ] I'll see you there listen
I want to thank Carlos again go to
college I was rocky calm I want to take
the flying [ __ ] Mizzou aka the Christ
killer but most importantly I want to
thank you guys for being [ __ ] savages
and for always giving us love Happy New
Year
have a great first week and we'll see
you [ __ ] next Monday tip top
Magoo ready to go wash your [ __ ]
[ __ ]
it's gonna be a good year thank you
again Carlos Thank You Joey well